[تصفيق]
سيارات ألفا تنخفض المدى
المرحلة
t زائد 30 ثانية تشير إلى
أن مهمة شرارة تلعب دور
الإلهام لقيادة الطاقم على متن الطائرة
وخنقها استعدادًا
لفترة أقصى ضغط ديناميكي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أم
[تصفيق  ]
هل تشعر بالضغط عليك أن تعرف أن
هذا الأمر ناجح ومهد الطريق
للمدنيين ، فأنت تعرف
رواد الفضاء المدنيين المستقبليين لن أقول الضغط
لأن الضغط يعني أنني أشعر
بالتوتر بشأن النتيجة هنا ،
وأعتقد أن هذه المسؤولية  هي حقًا
الكلمة الصحيحة وهذه
مسؤولية كبيرة وعلينا التنفيذ
بشكل جيد حقًا والحصول على هذا بشكل صحيح حتى
يظل الباب مفتوحًا لجميع
المهام الأخرى لمتابعة haley ماذا
قال لك طبيبك عندما أخبرتهم
أنك ستشرع في هذه
الرحلة حيث يبدو أنك مجنون ،
آه
ليس على الإطلاق ، لذا قمت بإرسال رسالة نصية إلى جراح العظام
قبل
إعلاني مباشرة وقلت للتو إنني حصلت على بعض  أخبار
للمشاركة وكلانا يعمل في st jude
معًا ولذا ذهبت والتقيت
به وقلت أنك تعلم في غضون أيام قليلة
أنه يمكنك التباهي بأنك وضعت أول
مفصل اصطناعي في الفضاء
وظل يقول كم هو فخور  هل
كان يعانقني وهو هنا
لمشاهدة الإطلاق غدًا مع
عائلته ، اعتبرتكم وسائل الإعلام أنكم يا رفاق
أشخاصًا عاديين يقومون بشيء
غير عادي ، لكن هذا هو السبب في أن الكثير من
الناس يشعرون بالارتباط بهذه
المهمة ، على الرغم من أن هذا
الوصف دقيق
أنا من النوع.  الشعور وكأنه يعني أنه
كان بإمكانك وضع مجموعة من الأشخاص
معًا
من جميع أنحاء البلاد
وستظل لديك مجموعة من القصص الفريدة
وراء كل شخص ، لذلك أعتقد أنه عندما
تفكر في كلمة عادية ، فأنت لا
تفكر بالضرورة  من
الأشخاص المملين اللطيفين لأن كل شخص لديه
قصة غير عادية ، فنحن مجرد
قلة محظوظة ولديها فرصة غير عادية
للالتقاء معًا ومشاركة
هذه الرحلة المذهلة التي لا تصدق
بالنسبة لي لكوني كبار السن  والأكثر
خبرة هنا التي تعرفها أه أعتقد أن الأمر
يتعلق
بعدم الاستسلام في أحلامك التي تتمتع
بالمرونة
والعزيمة والتصميم وهكذا أعلم أن لدي الكثير من
الأصدقاء والزملاء الذين هم في
الخمسينيات والستينيات من العمر وأنت تعرف أحيانًا
تشعر بأن أفضل جوانب حياتك
قد مرت عليك ولكن ليس هذا هو
الحال ، فهناك الكثير من الحياة التي لا تزال تستحق
العيش
في عصرك الذهبية وأحب أن أعتقد
أن هذا مثال على ذلك